la maglia bucata youtubers miliardari
bella dei ragazzi che sono io siamo sì
tropp face quest videogames è il
chinisia oriente serve troppi specie
sulle serie tv che io avevo già fatto ma
avevo fatto la versione demo
praticamente quale hanno aggiunto un
sacco quindi finché lo riferisco tutti
vedo riuscire a far visto che ce ne sono
tipo 39 in totale vedo di farne 20
all'episodio almeno a questo credo sia
perché io devo ovviamente come sempre
tentare di capire che c'è che serie tv e
credo sia non lo so non solo skillato
nelle serie tv così come nei videogiochi
quindi credo sia aggiunge ha sbagliato
questo potrebbe essere una sorta di
giovino da vecchio ok prevedere il next
level cosa ci porta come e saccheggiare
mamme che cosa struck spiega vite se tv
dovrebbe che peraltro è un incrocio tra
serie tv mm che non c'entra tantissime
anche le sappia grazie al tracciato in
fascia bruto pomodoro maledetto che
cacchio derivi a lo posso sbucciare era
un mandarino e bisogno su pomodoro e ne
resta sociale da parte o che l'ho fatto
allora fai schifo
valeriani avanti questo e spongebob per
forza credo sia sponge salve a devo
tener schiacciato nicchia non me lo
sarei mai aspettato la bella va avanti
kraft ospedale il sacro cuore va bene
queste scrubs fisso jd spiegami cosa
dobbiamo fare qua perché rompere fare è
che facciamo io mio jd fatato che i
capelli gli hanno fatto si allunga il
paziente
non trovo veramente nessun senso tutto
ciò questo è il primo video di youtube e
ragazzi questo lo conosco questi sono
gli elefanti dello zoo di non mi ricordo
questa prima di youtube
devo muovermi prima che scada il tempo
aiuto che cacchio successo
li ho fatti cagare signore signori il
mio intrattenimento su youtube kenny
aprirà anche se niente ma noi da sé sia
penny a star lì perché diventino
venturino mi ammazzate non lo so è che
non mi ha mai particolarmente preso
perché io non guardo le sue tv comiche
ok va bene questo problema non le guardo
è colpa mia lo so la compagnia fa niente
piace lascia mi chiama se forse devo
aprire questo non effettivamente capito
come si apre aprì la porta a porta il
demonio
lo vedo arrivare questi però non solo me
toglierli tipo aprendo la porta
no avidi è spuntato il costo per
cliccare qua per forza grazie grazie a
tutti
c'è una causa quella che non ho idea
questo è rientrato shining tutto ciò è
ora giovane una cosa ma cos'è
c'è una puntata dove lui fa shining non
lo so credo proprio di si sa che sono
non capisco la reference va bene c'è
scritto qualcosa nella doccia old troll
non avremo ben capito
la cosa interessante che non capisco
cosa sto facendo però a minchia lost
rowling troll va bene
vediamo se riesco a far uscire qualcosa
tipo la metanfetamina tipo che sarà anzi
stiamo proprio cucinando quella becera
fail non so effettivamente come farla
meglio di così non sono proprio k
secondo me devi fare uscire qualcosa che
non sia questo qualsiasi cosa che non
sia questo tipo di infilarci qualcosa
dentro che c'è da dire che walter white
è veramente uguale è un vasetto di merda
cos'è quello cosa mi rappresenta
in tutto ciò niente alla fine ha fatto
la stessa cosa al milione campioni però
è uscito un vasetto devo fare qualcosa
con questo sicuro ho fatto ok non poi a
lei più avanti non possiamo dare noi da
lui tipo tengo premuto lo alzo lo metto
qua eccolo è la merda nph e tamina
quell'ala credito vogliamo eccola qui
questa sì che è buona non trovo il senso
andiamo avanti ragazzi ma questo tipo
iss
cosa c'entra con le serie tv queste
morgan queste morgan e morgan punto
morgan non è in nessun altro se non
morgan
[Musica]
trolley j
ma cosa fa poi ora paparo proprio lui
proprio lui il troll mele madonna da
quant'è che non lo vedo ma saranno tipo
sei o sette anni tutti noi dobbiamo
vederlo
[Musica]
madonna era pazzesco sono passati 65
mila anni da tutto ciò fantastico
abbiamo il 20 questo è l'ultimo livello
ragazzi per oggi vediamo se sto a
cavarmela in modo decente visto come è
andata fino adesso secondo me no a
queste charlip it may
nel video di charlie bit my youtube
[Musica]
no ho sbagliato di vichy schiacciate si
ghiacciano schiaccia lotta che non sto
capendo effettivamente vi spiegate il
senso dall'alimento dito qua e poi ma
kraft due ore e la madonna
io l'ho staccato di netto mi stavo po
esagerato prova mentre ragazzi in questo
era spero ragazzi che il video vi sia
piaciuto questa la sorte smesso video
memes enti visions iscrive anche rare e
schede dal tasto mi piace ci vediamo
come episodio fanno gli altri 20 lungo e
geniale sempre nel mio cuore e sto gioco
per l'amor di dio è come se un ragazzino
ci vediamo al prossimo video delle
ragazze
[Musica]